I have pushed so hard like I just I do I
push so hard I I was doing all the
things I I hit a Breaking Point in
October and uh I like broke down crying
I went to Chicago I went to go watch my
friend Aaron run the Chicago marathon
and my sister and I were there and um I
remember holding this like packet of
pills that I was supposed to take and I
just said a broke I couldn't like open
it and I was like I didn't want to take
these and she said don't
and I looked at her and just started
crying and I was like I'm so [ __ ]
tired I'm so [ __ ] tired of trying so
hard and she's like you're not broken
like you're you're not broken
you're fine your body knows what to do
you are fine you operate just fine like
relax Let It Go and so there's that
spiritual psychological perspective of
focusing so hard on what's not right
that you keep getting more of it and so
I just kind of quit a lot of things I
told Mindy Pals has been my doctor all
year basically and
um or most of the year and she's been
wonderful and I just told her like I'm
tired like I need a break and she's like
okay we'll take a month I'm like I'm
thinking like the rest of the year so
um so we went into a really minimalistic
protocol where it was like I'd only do
like three things three things because I
was doing castor oil packs at night
coffee enemas in the morning red light
um uh pocket machine a lymphatic
drainage massages body work with lymph
with lymph movement I've tried
everything like it was just my daily
protocols on top of all the pills was
just extreme and I was exhausted and so
I've just simplified it so I simplified
it to a couple of things I simplified it
to uh Dr Ayman has a supplement called
happy saffron that has like 25 plus
um studies already on it of the positive
effect so for just mood and mood
generally
um so I've been taking that
getting in the hyperbaric chamber
because that one is my least favorite
because it's so boring but um but I do
that for one to two hours at a time when
I can the other one which is EMDR now
let me tell you about EMDR I think I
feel like it's going to get there in the
questions I think somebody asked
something that I thought oh this is
where EMDR will come in but I'll just
quickly preface it
highly recommended by Dr Raymond as well
and also my I mean for me I had tried
this with my therapist yes I have a
therapist I actually plan to almost
always have a therapist I don't think
there's going to be a point in time in
life where I just won't maybe for a
couple months at a time here and there
six months but I always plan to have a
therapist because the work should always
be on yourself like you can't change
someone else you can only change
yourself so that's my word of wisdom of
therapy and we did EMDR and it was like
time travel
time travel there's also another book
called I'm look I'm pointing because my
bookshelf is over there the body keeps
the score and it's a super heady book
and it's like got a lot of dense
information but one of the prevailing
therapies for peeling everything from
PTSD to depression and all kinds of
different
um emotional states is EMDR because it
is like time travel and when I heard
EMDR for the first time I thought what's
EMDR do you is this like a
do you take something is it like you
hook up to something it sounds intense
right but it's it's not actually all it
is and every therapist has a different
way of doing it so some kind of use
their finger and it stands for rapid eye
movement rapid eye movement something
desensitization so you're basically
bypassing your normal way of thinking
and being able to access your memories
in a new at this point in time instead
of in your old patterning
um so my my therapist uses buzzers and
they're just little vibrators
one in each hand and it just alternates
it goes
and you think of sort of like a trauma
that's happened something that
emotionally marks you like it's not like
when you got in that car crash although
that might be one of them
um it's what has happened in your life
that you have a vivid memory of that you
um had an emotional reaction to or that
you know kind of pops up in your in your
reality now as a as a memory or maybe
like the backtracking source of why you
feel the way you feel
um I had one akashic reader tell me like
go to the first and the worst meaning
what was the first time and the worst
time that you had an emotion come
through going to those first and worst
going to those deeply emotional
traumatic moments your mind just wanders
and you can't if you get your head in
the way it's totally not going to work
quite right you have to like allow you
have to stop thinking you have to just
let things come through and if nothing
comes through fine but I promise you
once as soon as you not mentally think
I'll just not think but feel like I'm
just gonna surrender and sit here and if
we just and have a good session today
fine that's when it comes through and it
is like re you're watching a past memory
from you're watching it as an observer
of your of yourself and you're also
watching the other person or the other
like whoever else is within the
situation
um and you not only see that but
sometimes I've seen
um how that person became like they did
or I've also seen Soul orchestration
where it's like I was aware that I
needed the experience that was difficult
to get me to where I went to give me
like uh uh to to stress me to to
challenge me to to give me some sort of
um an experience so that I knew how to
navigate something else more important
in the future I saw this like I like
literally like there is like a
controlling Consciousness or energies or
Angels or guides that are literally like
turning your head to look at a certain
thing happening so that you see it so
that you hear it so you can have the
experience so anyway EMDR really gives
you just this whole whole whole new
experience of an event that was really
traumatic and you go in and then you you
watch it's almost there's very much um
and this I'll say this later but like in
Michael singer's work with untethered
Soul it's about allowing things it's
about allowing an experience and
something that you something that's
going on to sort of go through you and
that ends up feeling like what you
really do is you you're watching it from
a wiser older perspective and you're
just witnessing it and you see it for
what it really is instead of what it
felt like then when you didn't have the
tools to navigate it better if you like
this clip and you want to hear the whole
episode click at the bottom of your
screen